well I got interested in reading very
early because a story was read to me by
hands Christian Andersen which was the
Little Mermaid and I don't know if you
remember the Little Mermaid but it's
dreadfully sad The Little Mermaid falls
in love of this Prince but she cannot
marry him because she's a mermaid and
it's it's so sad I can't tell you the
details because I might weep but anyway
as soon as I had finished this story I
got outside and I walked around and
around the house where we lived it was a
brick house and I made up a story with a
happy ending because I thought that was
due to to the Little Mermaid and it sort
of slipped my mind that I was only made
up to be a different story from me it
wasn't going to go all around the world
but I felt I had done my best and that
from now on Little Mermaid would marry
The Prince and live happily ever after
which was certainly her dessert because
she'd done awful things to win the
princes power I mean like his ease
because she had to change her her limbs
into she got she had to get limbs that
fee that ordinary people have it people
have and walk in them but every step she
took agonizing pain this is what she was
willing to go through to get the Prince
so I thought she deserved more than
death on the water and I gave her this
and I didn't worry about the fact that
maybe the rest of the world wouldn't
know the new story because I felt it had
been published once I thought about it
so there you are that was an early start
on writing stories I believe and tell us
how he did you learn to tell a story and
to write it I just made I made stories
up all the time I had a long walk to
school and
during that walk I would generally make
up stories and as I got older the
stories would be more and more about
myself as a heroine and in some
situation or other and it didn't bother
me that they weren't going to be
published to the world immediately and I
don't know if I even thought about other
people knowing them or reading them but
it was the story itself generally a very
satisfying one from my point of view it
would show you know it would be really
on the The Little Mermaid idea of it she
showed bravery and that you were clever
and the chewer in general able to make a
better world because you would jump in
there and and have magic powers and
things like that was it important that
the story was told from a woman's
perspective I never thought of it as
being important but I never thought of
myself as being anything but a woman and
there are many good stories about little
girls and women after after you've got
to be about oh I don't know in your
teens I think this stopped a bit it was
more than helping the man to achieve his
needs and so on but when I was a young
girl I had no feeling of inferiority at
all and being a woman and this may have
been because I lived in a a part of
Ontario where well let me see women did
most of the reading women did most of
the telling of stories
the men were outside doing important
things and they didn't go in for stories
so I felt quite at home how did that
environment inspire you you know I don't
know if I needed any inspiration I just
thought I thought that stories are so
important in the world
and I want to make up some of these
stories and I want to I want to keep on
doing this and it didn't in a way it
didn't have anything to do with other
people it didn't I I didn't need to tell
anybody and it wasn't until much later
that I realized that the stories that
would be interesting if one got them
into a larger audience yes what is
important to you when you tell a story
well obviously in those early days the
importance was the happy ending I did
not tolerate unhappy endings for my
heroine anyway and later on I began to
read things like weathering Heights and
very very unhappy endings would take
place so I changed my ideas completely
and and went in for the tragic which I
enjoyed did but what can be so
interesting in describing small-town
Canadian life you just have to be there
I think any life can be interesting I
think any any surrounds can be
interesting perhaps if I had I don't
think I would have been nearly so brave
as a writer if I had lived in a town and
if I had gone to school with other
people who were interested in the same
things I was and a general what we might
call a higher cultural level I didn't
have to cope with that I was the only
person I know who who wrote stories and
so though I didn't tell them to anybody
but I was the only as far as I knew the
only person who could do this in the
world you know for a while but we always
that confident new writing I was for a
long time I became very unconfident what
I became grown-up and met a few other
people who were right
and I realized that it was a much harder
job than I had expected
but I never gave up at all it was just
that's just something I did when you
start on a story they always have it
plotted out I do but then it often
changes I started with a plot and I work
at it and then I see that it goes
another way and things happen as I'm
writing the story but you have to at
least I have to start out with some kind
of fairly clear idea of what the story's
about and then indeed it may change how
consumed are you about writing when
you're into a story
desperate consumed but you know I always
got lunch for my children did I not
under that sort of thing but I was a
host wife and a fairly regular housewife
so I learned to write in the time times
off and and I I don't think I ever I
don't think I ever gave it up though
there were certain times at which I was
very discouraged because I get I began
to see as as you do that the stories I
was making up with the stories I was
writing we're not very good and that I
had a lot to learn and that it was a
much much harder job than I expected but
I didn't stop I kept don't think I
stopped for any length of time at all
ever what part is hardest when you want
to tell a story I think probably that
part where you go over the story and
realize how bad it is you know the first
part excitement a second part pretty
good and then you pick it up one morning
and you think what nonsense but you keep
then is when you really have to get to
work on it and for me it always seemed
worthy to do
it was my fault that it wasn't better it
was not the story's fault but how do you
turn it around if you're not satisfied
hard work but I've tried to think of a
better way to explain that you have
characters that you haven't given a
chance and you begin to think about them
more and do something more quite
different
sometimes with them and in my earlier
days I I was prone to a lot of flowery
prose and I would gradually learn to
take a lot of that out and and you just
you just go on thinking about it and
getting more and more finding more and
more out about what the story is about
which you thought you had in the
beginning but you actually have a lot
more to learn how many stories have you
thrown away huh when I was young I threw
them all away
um I I have no idea but I don't I
haven't done that so often in in recent
years I've generally known what I had to
do to make them live but they're still
still always a mistake somewhere that I
decide you've got to realize this is a
mistake and forget about it do you ever
regret throwing a story away I don't
think so because I think I've gone
through enough agony about it that I I
think this this really didn't work from
the beginning but as I say that doesn't
happen very often growing older how does
it change your writing oh well in a very
predictable way you start writing about
beautiful young princesses and then you
start writing about housewives and
children let me start writing about old
women it just goes on without you
necessarily trying to do anything to
change it your vision changes do you
think you have been important to other
female writers being a housewife being
able to combine household work with
writing you know I don't know about that
I would hope that I have been and I'm
not sure I think I went to other female
writers when I was young and that was a
great encouragement to me but whether I
have been to others I don't know
I think women have much I wouldn't say
easier time but it's much more okay now
for a woman to be doing something in
part not just to be fooling around with
a little game that she does when
everybody else is out of the house but
to be really seriously writing just the
way your man look right
what impact do you hope you have on
someone who reads your stories a woman
especially oh well I want my stories to
move people I don't care if they're men
or women or children or you know I want
my stories to to be something about life
that that causes people to not just say
oh isn't that the truth but to feel some
kind of reward from the writing and that
doesn't mean that it has to have a happy
ending or anything but just that the
everything that the story tells moves
the writer in such a way that you feel
you're a different person when you
finish who do you think you are what has
that expression meant to you over the
years
well it's a sort of classic expression
of I grew up in the countryside and I
grew up with people who were generally
scotch-irish and it was a very common
idea not to try not to try too much
never to think you were smart that was
another image that was very popular
oh you think you're smart and and to do
anything like writing you have to think
you're smart for quite a while and so
but it never it was never differed I was
just a peculiar person we're in an early
feminist I never knew about the word
feminism but of course I was a feminist
because that I well actually I grew up
in a part of Canada where women could
write more easily than men the big
important writers would be men but
knowing that a woman wrote stories was
probably less to her discredit than if a
man wrote stories because it was not a
manly occupation I mean that is very
much in my youth it's not that way at
all now what would it have changed your
writing if you had finished your
university studies it might have indeed
it might have made me a lot more
cautious and a lot more scared of being
a writer because the more I knew about
what people had done naturally the more
I was I was rather daunted and would
would perhaps haven't thought I couldn't
do it but I don't think that would have
happened really I think it would have
happened for a while but then I wanted
to write so much that I would have just
gone ahead and tried anyway
what's her writing a gift given to you I
don't think the people around they would
have thought that but I never thought of
it as a gift I thought of it as
something that that you could do I could
do if I tried hard enough but I always
thought of a trying hard enough
so if a gift it certainly wasn't an easy
gift after the Little Mermaid that was a
decent gift
did you ever hesitate the - oh good
enough all the time all the time I threw
out more stuff than I ever sent away or
ever finished and that went all through
my 20s
that I was still learning to write the
way I wanted to write so no it wasn't an
easy thing what did your mother mean to
you oh my I feel about my mother are
very complicated because she was she was
sick she had Parkinson's disease only it
wasn't diagnosed there had been
Parkinson's disease epidemic when she
was young and she needed a lot of help
and she she was difficult her speech was
difficult people couldn't tell what she
was saying and yet she was a very
gregarious person who wanted very much
to in to be part of a social life and of
course this wasn't possible for her
because of her speech problems so I was
embarrassed by her I loved her
and I in a way perhaps didn't want to be
identified with her because I didn't
want to stand out and say the things
that she wanted me to say to people and
so it became a difficulty that any
adolescent has many adolescents do with
a person who parent who is named in some
way and you weren't at that time to be
totally free of such things yes
did she inspire you in a way I think she
probably did but in ways I didn't I
didn't notice her understand I can't
remember when I wasn't writing stories I
mean I didn't write them down but I I
told them not to her to anybody but to
myself but the fact that she that she
read of course my father read to and
that my mother I think would have been
more
agreeable to somebody wanting to be a
writer she would have felt that was an
an admirable thing to be and the people
around me well most of them didn't know
I wanted to be a writer because I made
sure they didn't find out but it would
have been to most people ridiculous
because people most people to that I
knew didn't read and they they took to
life in a very practical way and my
whole idea of life had to be rather
sheltered from people they knew has it
been hard to tell a true story from a
woman's perspective no not at all
because that's the way I think being a
woman at all and that's sort of it never
bothered me I didn't realize I think you
know this is a kind of special thing
about growing up her I did
if anybody read it was the women if
anybody had the education it was often
the woman who had been a schoolteacher
something like that the way my mother
was and so the world of reading and
writing far from being closed to women
was much more open to women than it was
to men men being farmers or you know the
people who who did a different kind of
work and hoped or kind of work and you
were brought up in a working-class home
yes mm-hmm and that's where your story
starts as well yeah yeah I just I didn't
realize it was a working-class hold I
just looked at where I was and wrote
about it
yeah and did you like the fact always to
write on specific times looking at the
schedule taking care of the kids cooking
dinner oh I wrote whenever I could and
my my first husband was very helpful to
me he well he didn't actually do it and
writing it but but he what he did was
think of writing as an admirable thing
to do he didn't they
it's something that a woman can't do as
many the men are later Matt did he he
took it as something that he wanted me
to do and never never wavered from that
it was great fun in the first place
because we we moved in here
determined to open a bookstore and
everybody thought we were crazy and
would starve to death but we didn't and
we worked very hard
hello hello how important was the
bookstore from the beginning for the
both for the two of you when it's all
started well it was our livelihood
it was always hard yeah we don't have
any other source of income no the first
day we opened we made $175 what you
thought was pretty liable well we were
because it took us a long time to get
back to that again I used to sit behind
the desk and you know and look for books
for people and do all the things you do
in a bookstore and generally just by
myself or with my husband and people
came in and talked about books a lot and
it was very it was very much a place
where you people got together rather
than immediately bought things and
especially this is true at night when
I'd be sitting here by myself
and you know I would I'd have these
people that came in every night to talk
to me about something and it was it was
great it was a lot of fun and I had been
up until this point and in a housewife I
was a turmoil that I was a writing house
where but it was this the sudden
wonderful chance to get into the world
and and
I don't know I don't think we made much
money in those times possibly I talked
to people but too much instead of you
know getting them to the books but it
was a wonderful time in my life mm-hmm
you're I live in Holland and your books
paint remind me of coffee thank you yep
yes I live dry just outside of Amsterdam
take a nap man
yeah and I'm here and I oh I guess here
I am and and here you are more
importantly yes so um your books remind
me of home well oh oh yeah thank you
very much it's right in truck thank you
thank you what's nice I mean I love it
when someone comes like that and it's
not just a matter of getting autographs
it's a matter of telling you why you
know the whole thing
but today do you want young women to
read your books and feel inspired to
write I don't care what they feel as
long as they enjoy reading the book I
want people to just to find not so much
inspiration anyways it's great enjoyment
that's what I want I want people to
enjoy my books to think to think of them
as related to their own lives in ways
but that isn't the the major thing it
isn't something that I want people to to
do what am I trying to say I'm trying to
say that I'm not I guess I'm not a
political person
oh you're a culture person probably I'm
not quite sure what that means but I
think I am yes but you seem to have a
very simple view on things do i yes and
that you want I read some whether you
want things to be explained in an easy
way
yes I do but I never think I want to put
this ease more easily I just that's just
the way I write I I don't I I write
naturally I guess in an easy way without
thinking that this has to be made more
easy have you ever run into pearls where
you haven't been able to write oh I'm
trying to stay well I I gave up writing
just about how long ago was it a year
not a year ago yet but that was a
decision that was not wanting to write
and not having it was more a decision
that I wanted to behave like the rest of
the world in the sense that when when
you're a writer you're never quite like
other people you're you're doing
something as a job that other people
don't know you're doing and you can't
talk about it
and you just are always some finding
your way in this secret world and then
you're doing something else in the
normal world and I guess I was a little
tired of that though I'd done it all my
life absolutely all my life when I got
in company with more what should I say
not more practiced writers but who took
it in a more a way that was more
academic then I became a little
flustered because I knew I didn't write
that way it didn't have that gift so I
guess it's a different way of
approaching a story how you want to tell
it and how you want to work on mm-hmm
and I never worked on it in that very I
was about to say conscious but of course
that was conscious thought Ted I worked
it in in a way that comfortable pleased
myself more than in a way that followed
some kind of idea I think I could say
that did you ever see yourself winning
the Nobel oh I was a woman but there are
women who have won it I know I know um
no I didn't just because I I love the
honor I just love the fact but I didn't
tell no I I didn't think of that because
I think most writers probably
underestimate their work and especially
after it's done and they they they don't
go around to their friends saying guess
what I think I probably will win little
Bell prize
that is not a common way of greeting one
do I go back these things and read one
of your old books no no I am afraid -
I'm afraid - I'm afraid of wouldn't like
it I'm afraid something would know what
I would do I would probably like it
enough but then I would get a terrific
urge to change just a little bit here a
little bit there and I've even done that
in certain copies of my book that I
would take out of it covered it and then
I realized well it doesn't matter if I
change it it's not changed out there is
there anything you want to say to the
people in Stockholm who oh I want to say
that I am I am so grateful for this this
great honour that nothing nothing in the
world could make me so happy is this
thank you
you